la dragueuse du port de grand rivière
remise à flot le barrage antipollution
et quelques traces d'hydrocarbures à
peine visible voici ce qui reste de son
immersion lierre pour l'instant les
raisons de cet accident ne sont pas
déterminées ya un bateau il ya un gros
bateau qui est entré dans le port est
l'endroit qui devait faire demi tour
puisqu'ils rentrent à l'avant
c'est devant la drague c'est un très
gros bateaux et la fin d'un mythe auprès
de la dga rome mois une supposition moi
j'ai pas vu là maintenant 20 ans mène
une enquête pour savoir exactement ce
qui s'est passé on avait 500 de gaz et
dans la réserve et comme ça a sombré à
une partie qui est parti donc est bon
l'épopée ont fait le nécessaire
cette mésaventure a donc généré une
légère pollution dans le port qui bien
que maîtrisé inquiète la faune qui peut
être impacté par cette pollution dont
180 en plus de gasoil lui n'attend pas
il descend vers les côtes de méreau
fraîcheur bernaqua c'est dommage
c'est dommage on parle de pollution
pollution une pollution marine s'est
surpassée pas normal c'est pas normal
c'est pas une grave pollution mais quand
même ça j'en ai vu des gens n'aiment pas
voir contient de lune sous l'eau avec la
terre de l'île saint jeannais on n'aime
pas on encore assez pour que puisse
l'eau est saine
voilà il faudra patienter au moins deux
à trois semaines pour remettre la
joggeuse en état de fonctionnement